my love of kites started about 20 years
ago i taught math for 35 years
i just combined the two to try to reach
all of my students i figured why not
take this whole math lesson outside
maybe just maybe they would see the
relationship
[Music]
my name is winford randolph lowe
but in delray on the beach when i'm
flying my kites they call me randy the
kite
kegman
i started flying kite 20 years ago i
bought my first kite and i never looked
back i fly my carts as much as possible
i have about 60 or 70 kids
on any particular given day you can
paint the sky with sea creatures whales
scuba divers
you're not only looking at the kite
but you're looking at the strings
there's math there you can do something
with it
kites are geometric figures kites are
triangles and that is
one of the things that i tried to take
advantage of instead of doing it in a
classroom at desk we take them on the
field
pythagorean theorem is a formula used to
determine sides of triangles if we want
to use the staggering theorem
on the beach as we're trying to fly a
kite and we let the kite go and it
travels up the line better known as the
hypotenuse
if we draw a line from the top of the
kite down to the bottom that's side a if
we draw another line from that point
back to where we let the kite go that
would be side b
so by plugging those numbers into the
triangle we have just figured out how
long our string is from where we are
standing to the top of the kite here's
your answer we could do fractions common
denominators uncommon dynamics the more
complicated the numbers are the more
math there is
i retired six years ago we get a lot of
families to come on delray beach and
they have kids
and i teach math
i tell them see that right there
we could do a math problem with that you
know and some kids understand oh yeah we
did that in school
nowadays they see it but for a lot of
the younger kids uh it gets them
thinking too
[Music]
you